it's our parents anniversary so we're
surprising them with breakfast in bed
they're impossible to buy for
we think
we've never really tried
okay ready one two one two three
I'm sorry nothing's happening oh my God
yeah our kids walked in on us we were as
they say having sex that's not a
euphemism Phil that's exactly what we
were doing
having sex
in front of our children well they
weren't there when we started no
No in fact you weren't even there when
we started
oh my God oh my God it's okay maybe they
didn't see anything sweetie they they
screamed they dropped a tray of dishes
and then they ran out of here like they
were on fire you were on fire lady
really you're still going well forgive
me for thinking your zesty performance
deserves some praise Phil our children
are downstairs right now and they're
probably traumatized oh come on I'm sure
it's not that bad
whatever it was it looked like Dad was
winning it they were doing it he's no
idea what you're talking about sex yes I
know what sex is Alex it's when a man
and woman take off their underpants and
then get into the bed stop talking why
are they still up there yeah how long
does sex take oh my God stop talking did
you guys notice that Dad had the same
look on his face as when he smells a new
car
I need to leave I need to go to camp
this is gonna be so weird when they come
down let's just go okay come on
wait but I'm hungry we'll get breakfast
let's just go come on
let's go come on where you going
anywhere what is your mother I need to
talk to her I don't think it's a good
time right now she won't come out of her
room she's really upset isn't she big
time how'd you know we called
tell me exactly what she said I don't
know there's just a lot of screaming
where was your father when all this was
going on
he was right behind her
I guess it's better than having parents
who fight all the time
Maybe
my friend Jacob's parents are getting
divorced he has to move out of his house
they told him last week
that sucks
he'll get used to it half of my friend's
parents are divorced mine too it's
insane
so it's a good thing mom and dad still
do sex
better than Mom leaving the stove on
which she's done twice this month
I just realized we haven't even gotten
to the worst part of it yet which is
they're going to want to talk about it
maybe not
are you kidding their parents never
talked about anything so they want to
talk about everything yeah they called a
family meeting when we switched to one
percent milk
and uh I'm just gonna say it I'm really
sorry about what happened well we're
we're not sorry about what happened
we're sorry that you saw what happened
yeah okay they they get that let's see
uh no one wants to see their parents
my sensuality oh basically it's two
adults adults it's like you're shaking
hands but you're not using your hands at
all I can't handle a big family talk
about this we're not going to have a
choice so when they start talking just
smile a nod and think about something
else yeah it's easy just like at school
[Applause]
so I guess what I'm saying here is that
as you get older and
explore your sexuality you will discover
that as long as you are in a committed
relationship with consenting adults
there's really nothing to be embarrassed
about and let's face it your mom can't
keep her hands off me whenever the gun
show comes to town
really totally you talk to us on our
level but without being condescending we
did all right
I guess we did
yay us
I think we really handled that wow
you're excellent you were pretty good oh
this is such a weird day I know by the
way happy anniversary it always is
hey Mom can I get oh my God oh my God
enough [__] oh
[Music]